and the person is by the name of Clara
Oswald Jenna Coleman and guys this is
his first appearance at a Comic Con
over here next to me I didn't know this
is you guys Doctor Who
here they are this is your very first
comic-con you have been to one of these
before
no it's cosmic how do you feel they're
about 7000 people here who came out this
you can't even see the back
I didn't mean I've never been in front
of those before in my life
all those years of my this is a series 8
was amazing I absolutely loved it I love
the total shift of the show you are
phenomenal as the doctor I love I love
that you're kind of cranky and intense
and you sort of don't know he's a good
guy Erna and did you did you and Steven
talk about all that stuff going in the
season how we got had it to arrive at
this guy I think he just saw those
qualities in me and just cast me that
way
does that triangle see it's probably
maximizing what you've got with with the
new doctor yeah and what we thought
Peter could brings here but it's a lot
you know the truth but this isn't no one
ever quite believes me but the
difference in the way you write the
doctor isn't that great it's what the
actors bring to them that changes it the
cheese and emphases coming from the
actors and you kind of got to get out of
the way of that and facilitate it a bit
and as you see what Peters are doing
with it can do with it you start writing
towards it it's more than that on paper
the doctors are surprisingly similar
it's what you learn it's what each of
these brilliant actors bring to it and
how far into shooting do you start with
noticing there's a quirk or there's
something and I think I kind of like
what they're doing to sort of go in this
direction with it like oh how long does
it take for you to go it's pretty quick
actually because you're seeing it I mean
and there's a massive shock in the
beginning as he's somebody else you know
those first rushes which were for his
first appearance in deep breath
are we pop circuit artists that is the
first thing that he he shot apart from
the regeneration and so you've been even
quickly see what you know how it sounds
how it feels coming over that knew my
husband away you always want to solve
things
so what it is you do is start writing
for that boats computers are very very
distinct voice and Scottish which is
automatically better and for some reason
easier from a other we'd love to be
English before what difference is it it
doesn't make any sense
okay would he have an English accent
American accent Scottish jokes why
because a lot of places have a normal
you are going into this which did you
feel the weight of doctor immediately
had been unlike any other experience any
other show that you've worked on before
well it's it's the only show that I
think is in my bones by deeply it's the
only show that I've followed since I was
six years old so alone you know I was
thinking will have a very intimate
relationship with the program doctor who
even though I it now exists on the scale
which is which is huge wonderful it's
the only show that I've ever been in
that I really knew and loved and even
when I went and I did an episode with
David Tennant it was fantastic and I was
so excited to be there and I thought
that would be my only contribution my
only the only time that I would get to
be in Doctor Who and I remember turning
up on the set and saying to him David
Meister TARDIS and he took me over to
the police bolts in the car and I got
quite teary
that's a woman someday
duration going in again result to her so
I was thrilled that tell Stephen did
decide to governmental agent here are
yeah wonderful companion use the term
companion because I feel like you kind
of domed with a doctor this season a
little bit I mean it wasn't her
companion right now so you know did you
guys figure out like well let's you know
let's take a little bit of a turn to
Clara let's kind of make our character
really I mean we saw this old teacher
side of Clara I think maybe like the
earthbound side of Clara and then
actually I think I think a lot of us
series was about them working each other
out and working on this new dynamic it
is is going to work which is right
actually cuz we're shooting with mid
shooting at the moment and in a way
we're kind of we found our groove
together and then I feel like the arm
work really kind of terms both help
drive the TARDIS well I helped John
photographer I press a lot of buttons
and drizzle of Sydney you stick your
hand you know that jelly psychic stuff I
try to I get ready overexcited in them
and undersea Peter being very cool just
staring at me across the console I know
but this is also you know you were
managing a relationship the season and
so how do you have a relationship with
Danny pink had that factor in with their
buddies the relationship with you know
deal with filming right now yeah well I
mean obviously you can't befriend can't
really say what was your what was your
guys relation I think we were figuring
it out it was kind of quite experimental
it was I mean it's kind of like getting
to know your best friend all over
and the rules are different and dynamic
is totally different so it was a case of
all being thrown up in the air and
exploring together and seeing how it
falls suppose yeah look what Walking
Dead is like can you have a relationship
in the zombie apocalypse and it seems
like is it how hard is it to maintain a
relationship when you are a companion to
this man who snaps you up at a moment's
notice how you managed how do you manage
a personal life um well she has ruled
that she has to be dropped off like 30
seconds after she left the targets after
she left that was kind of a baby but she
that she doesn't actually live on the
TARDIS no she say now come and travel
through all the time in space with you
but only if you'll drop me off 30
seconds after I bled so you know I don't
miss like months class or something
right why do you think she doesn't
I think she's little control freak and I
think she's trying to trying to have a
pose by us at once yeah because she was
she basically lied to Danny oh but then
a big tangle of liars last series but
this series is much more
she is headfirst in the TARDIS with the
doctor right I want to talk to Michelle
for a sec about I mean you should be
caught up by now if you're here but
mistress see the art of her and seeing
all the speculation from that first
episode and then seeing Oh heaven
afterlife weirdness busy what was your
approach to this character as we got
crumbs of her throughout the season if
it's finally paying off well luckily I
never know why I'm saying what I'm
saying
so can I help arrived fresh just trying
to stay as present as I queued on the
day and obviously the right
it's all there for me one of the easiest
jobs ever my mind because it's it's just
it's just a thrill to turn up and be
given this opportunity to to be the
master I'm still sort of a pinch me
moment really and so I just hope that
you know as long as I knew my lines I
might turn about the day that some
little bit of magic would happen and
just you know we're really lucky that
the dynamic between the three of us was
sort of instantly really seemed to work
so who do you who do you think the
master is and what do you think she
wants ultimately I think he or she or it
is everybody's idea of the basic villain
you can have maybe it's like the head
place heavily the base trained and he
loves to hate that's poison away and she
gets to sell you stuff that we've made
but we're not allowed to say she just
has a kind of attitude where it rules
don't bind to her and that makes it
really fun to play but there was a
really nice moment at the end where it
just seemed like she just wants her
friend like it just seemed to be about
friendship where you would think well
there are these two opposing forces and
they're constantly and odds with each
other but the other two seem like oh I
just what happened to us I mean yeah did
you really break it down as like Hera is
this great friendship that just went
wrong you know we've all had them so
so it seems to be like a life's purpose
to kind of you know chase on to the
doctor and trying to make him understand
that you know though will you source is
it I'm right as long as if you're not
getting them so I'm your statement that
we have we trying to destroy the
universe which you know I really see
them how do you how do you define their
relationship
we are friends that's the terrifying
thing that's what's interesting with
them our enemies at all she sees our
change me the masters always beaten the
doctors best friend they're just fun for
his friendship between a vegeterian than
the hunter right now and indeed you just
have she never killed people
what do you think that you're making
sandwich right now right I'm in war yeah
absolutely heart liberal and I like to
kill people for fun that we don't have a
lovely time together
we both do the same thing we both kill
people he feels bad about that right
you see their business philosophy
but this idea where it seemed like they
were trying to this season to show do
you think the doctor understands who he
is do you think he's able to admit what
he is and do you agree with the
assessment of a lot of the story going
yeah you're a soldier like you're you
kill people you're not you know you may
not be a good guy now I think the doser
is I think the process of regeneration
is one that's as much of a shock to the
incumbent as it was to everyone else so
I think he doesn't know who he is
so he spent a moment I'm scrambling
around trying to find out what his
character is what his natures and
obviously in season eight I think he
struggled a lot with the fact that he
knew that he was compelled from within
to her to pursue the greater good which
would often mean that he would leave
wreckage in his path and he would do
that but he wasn't comfortable they
didn't know that that was a good thing
to do or to be so easy cost the growing
character I think he is he is not a
soldier you say he's a good guy umbrella
that there was no line and she fell
there was peace he'd rather sit in the
car park at night looking at the Stars
you know that I have to go on blow up
dawn acts
I like blowing up Daleks and I think he
enjoys it as well once it gets going
yeah I don't think he sees them as easy
it's not a military figure right he's a
sort of bohemian slash philosopher slash
read that I thought great Jan seems like
clarinets were struggling with whom he
was this season a lot too and it seemed
like there was one particular episode
where it seemed like there was a breakup
which genuinely made me sad at the top
of the episode we're like well this is
our last you know it just felt very much
like oh when you're in a relationship
you have one more time and maybe this is
it did she really believe that was gonna
be it I think I think she got scared
actually I think that it's the killer
moon episodes you're talking about the
big money at the end and yes yeah I
think I think she got scared and and
suddenly didn't feel safe maybe for a
moment but she was so used to having the
eleventh Doctor she was familiar with
how it was working and then suddenly
your best friend changes his face and
who knows what trans people it was just
getting to know each other all over
again getting to know somebody who you
described it to me as a bunch of going
into season one who's hurt who's had an
operation and who looks different and
who and you're going to see them in
there
it's it's like changing all the rules
basically yeah and do you think she's
starting to get into a comfortable place
oh yeah that very much T I think I think
that after the end of that to the end of
the series they're kind of they've found
their groove and they're very United in
the TARDIS kind of eating up all of time
and space with reckless abandon
excellence what could possibly go wrong
we are gonna take some questions in a
few minutes but right now I'm talking
about Series eight but I think now it's
a good time to spin a little bit and
start talking about Series nine we
happen to we happen to have a first look
never-before-seen trailer of series 9
seems like this is the appropriate place
to show that so let's roll preview for
series 9 doctor
it's called the TARDIS it can travel
anywhere in time space
you